hey how many of you have used cycle earn
crazy hands cool so you all recognize
this API you could fit things you could
predict things it's marvelous right so
psycho learn solves the supervised
learning problem where you're given data
next and targets Y and you wanna figure
out what F is okay and then cycle area
I'm gonna use these terminologies X is
usually a rectangular famous that where
you have samples as rows and features
that's columns and why it's usually and
samples and if it's a question it's
floats if it's classification it's
integers okay
now we're here to talk about histogram
gradient boosting alright okay
please thing so what is boosting it was
just boosting is very generic machine
learning term it's where you want
remember you want to pass me that s back
as function and it's a summation of many
different pieces of functions so that's
us boosting in general there's many ways
to boost its added boosting but today
we're talking about creating please
think gradient boosting is a special
type of thing and if you everything
about gradients and you're familiar all
networks you need like a loss function
right so we have loss functions and for
regression we have these squared loss
and for in our newest version 0 / 22
it's gonna be with this today not today
this month there's on least absolute
deviant deviation and for classification
there's cost and should be lost as an
example to make this kind of more tongue
I need a more concrete with focus on the
least square loss for this talk and for
my example V squared is just its you
could define a loss Y is you know why
during training F is the function trying
to learn and exit your data and this is
study squared loss just take the
difference in e squared you could also
now that you have a loss function and
it's gradient boosting
you can take the gradient of this note
that the loss is a scalar value this
gradient is now a vector value Y is a
vector effects as a prediction of
vectors
and it's gonna be it's gonna be the link
is gonna be as the number of samples you
have in training sets you can also take
the Hessian but in this case it's very
simple since it's it's one you learn
this all in like elementary school
calculus so great it's also a vector so
and it's effective it's unit it's one
for once ok not scared you do practice
foof Hey
so boosting remember boosting is we're
going to learn these series of functions
in our history and boosting we start
with an initial condition we start with
a constant we're going to give like the
most easiest prediction in the beginning
usually it's the mean for V squared for
cross-entropy is log odds ratio and
we're going to go through with the mean
so it's gonna be a constant beginning
and then that requesting condition looks
very much like great in the sense but
this is green this this is it's almost
exactly green and set but the gradient
is respected to the function so it's
taken a derivative respect to a function
there's a lot Matt likes it's Matthew
and the learning rate is a learning rate
just like in normal gradient ascent so
you make this kind of more concrete we
remember we had the gradient from three
squared we could plug it back in and
then we could define our function HFM to
be that little portion on the on the
left hand side okay thanks okay if you
squint really hard you can see that hmm
is the negative gradient it's just a
negative of it and now now this comes in
Chris relationship you start off with a
constant and then you're going to add on
to this constant these functions hmm and
then it slowly gets to your prediction
so now the goal is what is hmm how do we
get these hmm because it magic hmm maybe
lets you order example just to kind of
concrete five like numbers so let's say
um in this example um x is your age
let's say and Y is your income in
thousands of dollars all right very
simple you have one feature in this case
f of 0 is the mean it's a constant so
you can start off worse than me
so in this case the mean of Y is 78 so
that's my initial prediction remember
there's a term code there's a y - 8 H of
F 0 we could copy that that's the
difference between your predicted value
and the actual value you that sound row
column 4 and H of 0 is this thing you
want to learn right it's not gonna be
exact you see this H of 0 is trying to
predict the Y minus F of 0 and it's
gonna be you know it's gonna do its best
and you could and this is the first
prediction this is the first learner I
this is the first particular I learned
we could use in over again all right we
could remember the function was the
expression was recursive so you can add
ok so I moved F is 0 here and F H of 0
here and you add F of 0 and H of 0 to
get the next protection so in this case
the third column and then you could take
the difference again and you get the
difference and now the difference is now
smaller and then you do this recursively
you do it H of 2 and then just keep on
going all right this is the Bruce Lee
process okay so now so this is for
training for training you have these Y
values so you could take the difference
but during predict there's prediction
what you learn during the training
process is are these issues H 0 H 0 H 1
in this case since I boosted it twice in
prediction you you plug in your let's
say that I want to do I want to know the
income at age 40 you could plug in this
40 into these functions that you created
and then you get the prediction there
for looking time so you're learning
these functions H the thing is how do we
learn these HS this is trees we use
trees to pursue them so hmm
our predictions and they're trees not
necessary Christmas trees but trees okay
so now we need to know how to grow these
trees to grow these trees we need to we
need to we have to first for every node
we need to find out for every know that
we want to split
we have a look at each feature and we
have to sort this week here and then
find the best split point and then we
have to do this for every leaf node and
then after that because we could split
on the best node the thing is how do you
evaluate the split right if you do
random forests it's like there's a
purity ball it's like like but in this
case since we have a loss function
whether I want to optimize we could
remember this we have a loss function we
have these gradients we have these
sessions and we want to grow these trees
in such a way that it minimizes this
loss function right is this the ultimate
goal of this farm we this is I'm gonna
hand weight math here so you could and
generically you can write a loss
function as Taylor expansion of two to
the second degree so you have the
gradient Hessians and then you could
assume a tree structure so that every
sample goes to a leaf and then you do
fancy math and you get this gain array
which is you so in this case is how you
evaluate a split okay on the heat power
and each of ours are sums of gradients
remember these gradients before were
vectors so each sample has their own
gradient and you can sum dum and since
the same books end up and nodes you can
sum or the the samples on the left-hand
node and some everything on the
right-hand node and for every split you
could evaluate you can value the splits
this way I left out the regularization
in cycle learn the regulation is that 0
by default you can set it and I didn't
including expression but it's there so
now we have this thing right now we know
how to do evaluate split you just use
that gain thing we just saw are we done
no because sorting the feature it's n
log n because where n is a samples and
spinning finally the split point if it's
continuous values there's n no and split
points because of you if you have a real
valued data you could have many
different split points so this is pretty
slow so this is where we come to the
hiss of grading boosting
the hits party great in boosting so in
his great and boosting we have to build
these histograms but the first thing we
do to build these histograms is to in
our data and I thought really hard about
this visualization o where Y is the
feature and X is the row index so
normally your date it looks like this
it's a scattered it's not ordered right
um in this case I'm pinning with Ted
bins and what bidding does is it
discretized as your feature space so
everything on the on the object data on
the top bottom 10% is now one number and
this is zero the next 10 percent becomes
1 and the next percent becomes 2 and so
4 and so on so it's discretized the
freezer space so if you look at this and
if you look at this with the values
that's like just average or later it
goes from floats to ins okay so scree
typing binning magic okay so now that we
Bend our data and remember each sample
has their own corresponding gradients
you could now build these histograms of
gradients and Hessians in this case I
might been a bend with 5 and so for a
given known there's gonna be samples in
it and each sample will be in a bin and
you can sum up the ingredients of every
sample in a given bin and then build
these histograms where the y axis is the
sum of the gradients ok so now that we
have these things for a given node we
have these histograms we can now know
these because building histograms means
scanning through all your samples and
did the summing things up and now the
split points are finite because now the
spit points of our it's just the
thresholds between your bins you have
your protein you don't have to store
your features anymore because everything
in the first bin is less than everything
in the second bin everything is I
convinced more it's less than the
feature in it so it's ordered by default
and you have finite amount of fit points
you have n bin spit points in this case
oh and so this makes it much faster
so this lastly for histograms normally
when we end up at a node we all
have the histogram for that known so
this had this thing on the left which is
what we had before where we sum up the
gradients but normally we have butts on
the right which is we have already had
the gradients and Hessians for the
parent node so if you want to know that
gradients the Hessians the histograms
for the left and right we only need to
calculate for the one of them and then
take this the difference to get other
ones so you see there's a nice little
relationship here between the parents
and chosen so that's like the crash
course on how to build this stuff like
this is the few of the algorithm
remember why are we building these trees
like the whole point of doing all this
magic was serious of all this math like
magic of masses oh do all this math was
to find these hmm so I think we sum them
up to approximate this app right that's
the whole goal of this matter so now if
we step back a little and go through
what it feels like to be data going
through this algorithm in chronological
order
um first in the algorithm we've been the
data as we saw before
then we make a initial prediction which
is a constant and then since we have our
predictions now we get the gradients and
hands and then we go to the boosting
process okay so this is the algorithm
like like 10 feet above like Tuffy's not
too high but yes okay so this is the
algorithm so now let's talk about the
implementation so how do we implement
this since I can learn your Python well
that can be awfully slow because most of
this is procedural code like if you
think about implementing what I just
described it's very procedural we could
do it numpy but we do do it on file you
do you some pipe but most of the speed
ups and lamp I comes from doing
vectorized operations or using glass and
I'm using linear algebra but as you can
see there's it's barely any leaving
algebra here I'm just summing up things
and trying to do things very
procedurally so we do write it insight
on and if we use pure sight on it this
would be okay it runs
see early and it'll be okay
but it won't be as quick as our
competitors like like GPM and actually
boosts and actually like you can match
keepers and so we take advantage of
OpenMP which allows us to paralyze our
cold okay um so how do we take advantage
OpenMP it's who makes icon like kinda
cool is it gonna apply to you guys all
right so I thought is a way to write
Python it's very similar to Python but
you can compile it and it runs much
faster that's the gist of time so I'm
gonna show you parts of the code where
we take advantage of
openmp and see what it looks like
alright so submit there's many ways to
paralyze our code and you could paralyze
it this I'm just gonna show you so
finding out data once we've been out
data we have to map from the view values
to the integer values and that's a
binary search if I didn't do it and if I
do it inside time it looks like this you
just have normal range if you didn't
python it also looks like this so excite
that i'm python it's really nice yeah
technically all these are memory views
but anyways so you can use range and
this works is a serial but what you do
to use openmp and and you set up a
compiler I think Apollo this with OpenMP
is you change the range into a P range
and and then you release takeo and bam
magic it works
right so this is um parallel this is
take advantage of or your cores and it
it makes it go faster you're doing bite
yeah
though that's debating that of the data
coding histograms this is the same way
in this case I'm reasoning to go another
way it was a context manager and this is
to shoot this is um since building the
histograms are independent its bearing
system for one features independent for
burnin kiss champ for another feature
you could paralyze this as well so you
could build the feature the histograms
for each feature independently and so
you could tissue it to work okay so this
is its so if you want to do this in and
with openmp you just use p range and it
it works you do it for this you do this
a for the subtraction thing we're just
all so
so yes so you could just you could
distribute the work if you find if you
want to find the best splits and after
you find that if you want to find the
best bits to find the best business you
could also paralyze it through the
features and you use P range if you are
splitting this one's a little more
interesting the splitting with n threads
so your your manually you manually
separating the work between two each
thread in this case so you could
dislodge X you could do for openmp one
thing to note is that for in this case
I'm updating Hessians and this is just
writing memory in parallel right this is
I'm not doing it much this is I'm not
doing much work I'm just paralyzing them
writing to memory and all that also
makes it faster so it's very nice very
useful okay if you want to make scythe
on things faster all right so okay so
it's I recommend if you raise the right
side on that it's if you want to speed
up speed up your code if you if sight on
since like I run this serially and you
want to make it cool run in parallel
it's very nice to use OpenMP it's really
cool it's very simple to use that you
saw all my ranges has become P ranges so
have at it I guess next so that's OpenMP
so let's step back again to like the
history including boosting this is kind
of more apply so there's not there's a
like hyper parameters in our history I'm
grading boosting I'm gonna go through
all of them and it's not that many it's
not like it's not crazy it's not like
millions
it's like Ted and that's Han funny so
let's um there's easy to conceptualize
because you know the algorithm you know
that so depending the data we have seen
the Carmack spins it's the number of
Bin's okay that's it
so the initial positions the gradients
in the Hessians you you need a loss
function right how do we define a loss
function there's for real question we
have to like I said before a classifier
you have something called Auto which
decides for you if you have a binary if
it's a site for you from your train
if you change that is binary use binary
class entropy if it's multi classes use
categorical cross entropy and there's a
regularization so that's that was hyper
parameters now that the more interesting
ones are the boosting ones at the
boosting ones where the boosting you
remember it's the boosting is how many
estimate how many trees you want to grow
in this case so we have two learning
rate let's we described before we have
max inner which is the number of trees
you want to grow let's look at let's
look at the graph of this and this one
do you want to take a picture sure so if
you look if you look at the graph of
this on the x-axis it's max knitter is
how many trees you have and y-axis is
our two score it's which is the metric
you look at you see that the training
score increases monotonically well the
test score signs out which is kind of
what you expect if you at some point you
add more trees it does nothing to you
test that ok now remember there's
another there's another hyper parameter
called the learning rate by default is
zero point one let's say I just go crazy
I make it zero point five is the dotted
line is what we had before all my home
example is the down line is just this
this one all right so I'm comparing it
to this original one so now the solid
line is the new the new score as it
evolves with the number of trees you add
in this case the total earnings dew
point five that means that you see it
shoots up it over put it over fit and
now the test score goes down so now it's
overfitting so that the learning rate
the higher the learning rate the more
your model will over fit okay okay
growing the trees growing the trees
there is some there's hyper parents to
grow the trees there's these the max
leaf nodes is how many nice notes you
have in your inventory
max depth is set to none which means
grow as much as possible given these two
other conditions and many samples leaves
is how many samples will end up in a
giving leaf so in this case these are
the false 20
forgiving leaves only 20 gets into value
max okay so let's mix likes look at some
graphs again this is max as you see by
default is 31
31 31 and if you set it to 200 you see
that it will over fit your data it will
over fit your data and um yeah we're
Fitz boom now I've lots of things that
over fit if I said max def to like
something like 3 this is a case where
under fits because all you choose are
now short and stubby and uh they were
underneath it you see all the grass to
move down I skip I skip this in the
training process we also have early
stopping so there's a condition you can
set up so that early stops as in it's in
the beginning its explicit with data so
that has about a separate validation set
and while it goes to trees it checks
this validation test to see if there's a
if the early stopping condition holds so
I'm gonna tell you the parameters that
control this early stopping procedure so
there's a scoring there's a validation
factions which is how much of your data
set you want to leave out for or a
stopping there's any there no change
it's set to none which means no early
stopping you have to set it to a number
to make an early stop and there's a
tolerance which is how if when it
compares your score to the to the best
score seen so far this is the tolerance
it has okay so let's look at what it
looks like to early stop let's say the
bottom line is what we had before if it
doesn't really stops it's continues on
and as you suspect if I said I'm a
knitter no change to ten it already
stops when 10 after 10 rounds of adding
trees if the score doesn't get better it
just stops alright
I have 25 minutes is good okay so
there's miscellaneous ones there's like
rebo's mode which I'll show you soon
because that's the terminal you saw
before
there's random safety control the random
state and there's also an environmental
variable that controls the number of
cores your algorithm uses okay and it's
um it's okay
oh and um dreads okay so I'm in this
case I did set it to 12 so I'm gonna
showcase what this looks like with I'm
going to show you some benchmarks for
for the Higgs boson data set which has
88 million records and 28 features it's
a binary classification problem and one
means there's a signal which means
there's a zero means it's background so
and I'm gonna compare it to the other
libraries in this case I said benchmark
is really hard in this case because
everyone has everyone has different ways
to grow trees and what's constant among
some is that they you do boosting so
they have the add trees and they have a
learning rate and so they all do the
boosting process so in this case I set
the max 80-100 learning rate to 0.1 and
I use all 12 cores and then you have you
can see that the first three are MSU SK
learn and like GBM are equivalent in
time to train and have similar accuracy
and ROC ok so let's say I said max it er
to like 500 let's say um some longer
time um you could see that sq learn like
GBM are amongst the same and the RC
scores it got better like these you have
more treats like it got better
yeah the cool thing is that cycle learn
is written in Saipan and GPM own spirit
and keepers in C++ and it's pretty cool
that we get this performance just from
writing side on ok most of you don't
have 12 core machines so I ran this on
my laptop as well so I ran on my laptop
I got 85 second for 100 rounds and I got
85 seconds and sayings for like GBM 88
86 and accuses 115 so it works its magic
I'm gonna I want to show you a demo of
dev verbose mode and see how it takes
advantage of your course this is awesome
so I said X all right so I set it to 12
this is a 12 core machine I asked
into it and it's and that's the script
that runs the benchmark in this case I'm
making 50 trees in this case and so this
is this would hopefully run I call it
first it bends the data and then it
shows you how long each tree is taken on
the right hand side you can see that is
using 12 cores
it has 12 course and have it has hyper
dreads but OpenMP is really bad hyper
threads so you should set it to the
number of actual cores you have and then
BAM like this is 1 through 8 point 8
million records and topic and it's did
it in 20 seconds in this case because I
used 50 and it's cool all right demo
right shoots a row man this was on a
road map but it has been added missing
values it's coming in soup 122 if your
data has missing values and you call fit
and predict it works so this is this is
the first estimated we have a secular
that natively supports missing values
and it's it's nice right what we have on
the after is your 122 a feature road map
is categorical features or discrete
which will speed up training sparse data
support which is sparsely the support
and I'm symbol waist with with there's a
PR in sample weights and AD example
weights to this would be nice
um now um that's the conclusion please
use it this is how you use it
enable gradient boosting and it's
experiment the feature so you have to
have this importers if you want to try
out the dev build which is the one this
is is this is the build that supports
missing values that's how you install it
and all these slides and all the my
benchmarks script is in this repo great
and boosting it's wonderful
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
no but we could I don't see why not we
don't we don't support that right no no
no what do you job there's different
with power lines and openmp in this case
the procedure code is ingrained in the
algorithm open job lip once edge to
multiprocessing
job then you have you use it works in a
way where you your pipes and processes
are on different cords in this case the
algorithm is actually running of course
so it's different
that's it was question there have a
question so just just uses bidding yeah
you used to be just like a gradient
boosting classifier which i think is
different or aggressor wondering what's
the trade-off in terms like model
performance when you use the binning and
versus not using the bidding and how you
decide like what bidding strategies to
use in this in the traditional gradient
boosting in cycle earn we don't bend we
do what we had before we do the sorting
pit and um it doesn't bidding actually
makes everything better
because it's there's no reason not to
been in mind and there's no reason to
make the bin size smaller you control it
if you want
oh there's a reason you could study it's
faster than training but keeping the pin
size in as 255 in this case it's the
best and it's much better than great the
al traditional gradient crusing
estimating
it's not much of a trade off it's good
in general I think I want to go back and
forth yeah yeah I'm non GPU I think you
asked this question Syfy oh there's a
there's a another package that's use
this number and while we develop this
and we have not considered putting on
GPU what if if number becomes a
dependency if I can learn or scifi then
yeah but if like we don't adding new
dependencies is something we try to
resist so and yeah we will experiment
them maybe we save a bin for missing
values and we scand left to right and
it's kind of in-depth so I guess Nick
knows all about it and he's TC Zoe but
we can talk after I hope so you save it
then for missing values that's why our
bin size is 255 it's not 256 we store
everything as un8 which you think is 256
but we saved one with bins for missing
and that's the magic right quick yeah I
love to talk about it oh it's it's zero
zero and it's it's you're in the code
zero um we do have a min Hessian and an
algorithm that caps the bottom so it
works with men I think it just works and
it's in the code and I think I don't you
know the answer that what why is the
really puts the regulation equal to zero
sure because I'm the auger is inspired
by GPM and we Nicolas spend a lot of
time going to a sipper source code and
figuring how to cite own eyes it and it
turns out they set out to regulation to
zero oh no no no it's Oh
all right so it's Oh - it's it's the the
regulations on the squares scores of
some of the square scores of your trees
so it's not it's not depending on the
loss function it's if the regulation is
on the scores itself on the on the on
the leave it's yeah so it's an it's
independent of your your your loss
function it's it's rated - it's really
the tree part yes you have the same
trees all right okay hey thank you for
coming